if we really want to improve a person's
health and make sure that the population
is healthier we have to create a culture
of wellness in this country the things
that are going to actually help you or
me stay healthy are not necessarily the
things that happen inside a doctor's
office they are the things that allow us
to choose healthy lifestyles on a
day-by-day basis the things that nudge
us to get more exercise to eat healthier
to quit smoking or not stops start
smoking in the first place and business
employers have a role to play in this
because they often create the
environment that makes it it makes it
easy for people to choose those healthy
choices schools have a role to play here
because schools are where kids learn the
lessons of a lifetime in schools have
the opportunity to create those
environments where kids can choose a
healthy lifestyle and our policy leaders
have a role to play because they are the
ones that that enact the zoning laws and
and the helped us create a built
environment that either encourages or
discourages healthy lifestyles so I
think that the things that will actually
make a difference and be low tech in
improving our health are not the things
that happen in the healthcare system
they're the things that happen in the
larger environment and will create a
culture of wellness we spend over two
trillion dollars on medical care but of
that 95 percent of it is going to treat
people not to preventive preventing
illness in the first place
when you talk about prevention it's
important to understand that a lot of
the things that we can do to prevent
illness primary prevention happen
outside of the healthcare system
clinical prevention colonoscopies
mammograms things like that are
important but
just as important and in fact perhaps
even more important are the investments
in community-based prevention that keep
people healthy we know that for every
dollar that we can invest in
community-based prevention we will get a
return on an investment in about five
years of five dollars and sixty cents
that is a great return on investment